how much of an economic impact would
this sale potentially have well long
story short we don't really know and it
may not be enormous but let's just look
at some of the numbers and remind
ourselves that this is not about
changing the whole of the UK's
relationship with the EU that remains as
it was it's mostly pretty much entirely
about Northern Ireland and here you can
see map of the UK I've shaded it so
different parts the red of those areas
are the more GDP the more economic
growth they're generating that's
relevant you'll see why in a second but
for the meantime let's just focus on
this it's really in large part about the
IRSC so it's about that border there in
the IRSC and of course the border on the
island of Ireland right now about 65 of
all of the purchases in Northern Ireland
that don't come from within Northern
Ireland come from the rest of the UK so
you've still got lots of stuff going
from over there to over there you don't
see on the surface there's been much
impact from brexit but you do when you
drill down because there's certain Goods
particularly agricultural Goods that are
more difficult to get across and if you
look at the goods that are coming from
the Republic of Ireland through to
Northern Ireland here's what you see
fruit and veg Dairy and eggs look at
that's the end of the transition period
and have a look at what happens after
those go up so you've got more Goods
coming from the Republic through to
Northern Ireland and less going across
the Irish at least with these categories
and the hope is this deal changes that
so you have Freer flows across the IRSC
will that make much difference in the
kind of grand scheme of things well
remember here that Northern Ireland is
about two percent just over two percent
of total UK GDP so even if it's
fantastic for Northern Ireland you may
not see that showing up on total UK
figures remember the UK still has that
relationship with the EU the brexit
relationship with the EU are hard brexit
effectively and London in comparison
that's about 24 of GDP just to put in
perspective but one hope is potentially
this does Boost something else this is
business investment how much money
people are putting into the UK from
overseas in particular and you can see
it went down post-brexit here's where it
might have gone were it not for brexit
that's a kind of counterfactual that's
been designed by an economist at the
bank of England and the Gap there it's
about 1.3 percent of GDP may not sound
like much but actually that works out at
about a thousand pounds per household so
the hope is that this deal might start
to change the mood to repair some of
that damage